[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight update video there are some brand
new spoilers hot-off-the-press so if you
do not want to be spoiled I would highly
recommend leaving this video now but if
you're a game of Thrones junkie like me
then by all means please proceed today's
news is compliments of Watchers on the
wall and there is some new details
coming out from the Winterfell set
someone posted a video on Facebook and
it appears like they are driving past
the Winterfell set in the entire castle
was up in flames the quality of this
video and photo is very poor but you can
clearly see there is a orange glow with
tons of smoke covering Winterfell it's
hard to say who is burning this castle
right now but I know the fire appears to
be red and orange but that does not mean
it's not the night king vissarion's fire
is blue but they would have to use CGI
to make it that color the fire we are
seeing here could be from the night King
but they will have to make it blue when
they do their After Effects but this
could also be fire from another enemy
Cersei could have sent the golden
company north along with Joran Greyjoy
looking at a photo from this distance is
too hard to tell but we know there will
be a battle at Winterfell there were
some other photos from this said just
the other day and at the time there were
over 200 extras on set and you could see
all of them running around with weapons
in their hands
Winterfell will clearly be under attack
but the million-dollar question is by
who
the night king is coming from the north
in Cersei could be sending her troops
from the south
Jon and Daenerys could potentially have
to fight a war on two different fronts I
was hoping the magic within Winterfell
would keep it from falling the castle
was built by Brandon the Builder and the
children of the forest so you would
assume this castle was very special but
the knight King has a damn dragon now
and that dragon already brought down the
magical wall so he may be capable of
just about anything
there will be an x factor though
Daenerys has two dragons of her own and
Melisandre should be showing up as well
and she could possibly be bringing her
own weapons of fire that can counteract
the knight Kings ice magic Melisandre
still has a massive role to play and
whatever it is will cause her death so
there is no telling what kind of demons
she could summon upon the army of the
Dead whatever it is it should be very
interest
to see more and more spoilers are
starting to come out and everything
that's taking place in the north is
getting me very excited unfortunately
for the Starks they may have to abandon
their ancestral home and flee from the
north I don't want to go too far down
that road right now though because there
just isn't enough information or
evidence yet the only thing I can
confirm is Winterfell is about to take a
serious beating I just hope that as long
as there is a stark in Winterfell they
can overcome whatever attack this may be
I think we are going to need to see John
ride Ragle as soon as possible if they
want a chance at stopping the night king
and his massive army John and Daenerys
will need to throw everything they have
at the night King and even that might
not be enough but only time will tell
I have made a few different videos where
I discuss how I think the Great War will
end but anything is possible at this
point
another photo was recently posted online
and it showed a handful of characters
arriving in Iceland which is very
interesting as well if you look at this
photo you can see tormund Brienne Jorah
Samwell Tarly and ginjury is right
beside Sam but he's kind of hard to see
John and Daenerys arrived in Iceland as
well and these photos do confirm two
things
Gendry will be back in torment is still
alive but what makes this even more
interesting is the fact that they're in
Iceland they typically only film here
when they are shooting scenes beyond the
wall but now that the wall was down in
the night King is south why would they
need to go back up there could there be
something beyond the wall that they need
to find or could they force the night
king in his army back up north like the
last hero did or
is the winter so severe now they have to
film in Iceland to depict a long night
type winter the night king typically
brings the storm with him so I am
thinking we could see Winterfell like
we've never seen it before if you
remember old main story then you should
know when the long night falls upon the
world things can get very intense snow
falls over a hundred feet deep people
freeze in their castles and people
starve and so on and so forth
whatever they are doing in Iceland has
me intrigued but I have a feeling most
of these scenes they are filming there
we'll just be in the north and not
beyond the wall because winter is here
and most of the north should look like
the landscapes in Iceland I don't want
to do a whole lot of crazy speculating
though because there just isn't enough
information right now but I told you I
would keep you up to
with whatever is going on so let me know
what you think down below do you have
any fun theories for why Winterfell is
burning and what does this mean for the
Starks I'm curious to see what you think
thanks for stopping by for this quick
update video I appreciate everyone for
watching and I also want to thank my
patreon supporters have a great night
everyone I'll see you soon but
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]